[Música]
eu perdi meu pai quando tinha três anos
é e quanto mais realmente noção da falta
deu
é ela estava longe de imaginar que algum
dia iria ter a oportunidade de criar uma
inteligência artificial dessa hipótese
de me encontrar com ela
bom é todos nós iremos morrer um dia
ou não eu sempre fui fascinado por amy
pela vida é oficial
é este temos aqui vemos é o jogo da vida
que é no fundo um alta um autômato
celular criado com o matemático
britânico j horta no canal e 1970 que no
fundo representa é vir eu sempre fui
fascinado pela o conceito deste jogo que
na realidade se formos ver bem não é
exatamente o jogo no entanto se formos
olhar para a vida em si como um jogo
chegamos pra ela que se realmente fosse
um jogo então o jogo da vida é realmente
um um jogo é os primeiros momentos que
eu tive pré de ligação ó o mundo obscuro
do seu espaço foi quando joguei pela
primeira vez já imensos anos usando um
móvel de 2.400 mortos provavelmente
muitos de vós irá lembrar se ão desse
tipo de modelo em que entro num na área
ou num num espaço é completamente e
teriam e ainda sem nome é e e à espera
de ser descoberto é imediatamente
fascinava é e e não sabia que realmente
é essa é esse universo paralelo chamava
saiba os países o termo saiba país para
quem não sabe foi realmente criava com o
escritor o ny e neste um dos que mais
que é o barman crohn
é e depois por estréias do douro a massa
foi é é o tipo de livro que nos
transporta para algo é completamente é
artificial e que nos move para o outro
para o outro mundo o ciberespaço é
transmitir uma alga e deixou há algo no
meu adrienne foi uma espécie ou pelo
menos esta experiência que tive espaço
foi o que foi eu deixando sementes no
meu abiec espera é realizar algo no
futuro se foi um ensinado como disse da
vida é oficial e que criar algo de
diferente e surgiram é é as primeiras
idéias para criar uma rede social é que
em que tenta juntar o tempo aos três
ciclos do tempo passado presente e
futuro num tempo só seja basicamente
tenta fazer o impossível é algo com que
eu me identifique tentar transformar um
pouco que o que muita gente pensa que é
impossível numa numa camada só numa
camada temporal só o inter neste mês
estamos aqui quer ver é é é uma parte da
plataforma contém alguns agentes
virtuais é que crescem o nash na própria
renda e esta gente chama se é é online é
um agente puramente virtual que nasceu
tentar carreira méxico uma das
principais características deste é desta
plataforma é é a clonagem virtual de
cada utilizador para utilizador quinta
na rede automaticamente com na
digitalmente e é lhe atribuída uma
contraparte essa contrapartida vai
permitir que o utilizador é essa é
substituído na sua ausência é também uma
das principais é um dos principais é
principais características que permite
que o utilizador e ganha chamada
imortalidade é digital e podemos ver
aqui o córtex temos um nome e córtex
de um tesouro em que não a temos a
partor é orgânica do outro lado temos a
parte é parte vital
nós quando estivermos eh eh eh eh parte
digital ou a nossa contraparte e
realmente é alimentada por todas as
nossas interações que fizemos dentro e
fora da renda é o sistema está a
mastigar um conjunto de informações que
existem fora por terminados
comportamentos que nós temos é é um isos
guarda guardas numa nova dos pais numa
base de conhecimento depois mastigou
mais tarde
é impressionante a posteriori fazendo
com que quando eu estou em alfano eu
consigo que a minha contraparte faça
parte do meu trabalho digamos o online
esta parte está aqui de propósito não é
um flyer em branco não pode ser um fardo
em branco porque é representa realmente
é é um pouco do meu histórico eu eu
cresci é no ambiente é muito cinzento
falar tanto com muito poucos recursos
nessa altura eu conseguia ver o mundo
com mais com mais cor
lembro quando tive o primeiro contato
com os computadores e e devo um pouco é
eu não sei como é que eu consegui
encontrar nem sei como é que eu
encontrei dinheiro para conseguir
comprar um computador que na altura eram
681 consigo né em inglaterra mas havia
um véu que distribuíram para portugal
plata e maxwell também 5.000 isso mudou
estava dez contos em moeda antiga já foi
há muitos anos
foi no em 82 e esse estava certo com o
irmão era um aficionado por ser um meio
tal como eu é um ano mais velho que eu
acho que conseguiria fazer a montagem
desse de desktop e e se fecha e mandámos
vir 11 um kit com 11 500 que era uma
futura que volto a dizer não lembro onde
é que onde há que arranjar mais dinheiro
e vai buscar isso
mais próximos estavam acho que as apps
quilômetros e de distância e não estamos
a pensar e buscar isso ó ó rei de
bicicleta não tínhamos outra mãe para
fazer pré al de onde eu estava e o mais
engraçado é que nessa altura em que os
filmes o postal alguém que eu já nem sei
como é que foi
lá iremos buscar o encomenda o meu irmão
tinha feito qualquer coisa num pé estava
com o pai para nada e então alugamos um
táxi mas de nenhum vizinho para ir
buscar é o que eu acho que é esse tal
era a nossa euforia não podia esperar
mais tempo e quando chegou que
curiosamente eu vinha com um erro
qualquer no no esquema e um irmão com
isso dentro de um voltado para aprender
é fazer as coisas naquela naquela altura
tentava ser um autodidata o mais
possível para tentar ultrapassar algumas
barreiras do qual nunca teve
conhecimento era 1 mil também é
conseguiu montar outro argentino num
esquema é vê lá alguns erros propositais
ou não sai é que caso não conseguirei
voltar para trás enfim conseguiu por
aqui vou montar montado era a preto e
branco tal como a televisão tinha
desligado ea primeira coisa que eu faço
olho para que um em mais uma coisinha
pequenininha que aquilo era um deus que
conseguia fazer coisas maravilhosas é e
como eu sempre fui muito
gostei sempre coisas do universo e o
espaço em si está aqui uma vez só vai
falar de coisas interessantes que eu vou
ver cidadania e fotos de ouvida pela
assinadas com o espaço foi fabuloso que
o design o planeta saturno e uma mesma
eu tentei ler o manual na medida do
possível e que deu o ok bairro caiu 0
barra 0 não mudou nada foi que eu fique
as máquinas precisa precisariam ser
ensinadas e precisariam de realmente ter
o humano teria que haver uma interação
mais completa com com um ano depois é a
partir daí eu comecei a desenvolver
coisas como a que vem sendo cada vez
mais pupo a máquina o código de máquinas
zeros e uns fascinavam eu conseguia ver
a cor é no ambiente preto e branco
curiosa
é perfil desse espectro que afetaram a
imagem de um destes livros e é apesar da
previsão que usava era a preto e branco
eu consegui evitar 11 vislumbrar um
pouco o que eu pretendia fazer e muitas
dessas idéias surgiram por começou a
falar em alguns livros que não corta em
onda mas de algo relacionado com
inteligência artificial muita do erro e
achei que viria mais tarde ou mais cedo
construir ao transformar algo quem deve
e de ficção científica em algo real
porque porque eu via séries como espaço
1999 star trek e outras até o alto - que
eu adorava 01 um homem puramente virtual
e e um cursor a volta não se lembram
desses tempos e uma chave é que pra mim
era real e essa é interessante
mais tarde não olha para as coisas que
você nem perceba as massinhas som é
perfeitamente possível por isso aqui
hoje essas camadas jovens é encaixam
muito mais as tecnologias continua
exatamente o foco ea evitar a espera
muito muito ceticismo não vêem tudo isto
com uma naturalidade é muito maior do
que provavelmente nós que o tempo e e
facto uma ficção científica é o já
vivemos uma era que é ficção científica
real aqui uma característica
interessante eu estou eu vou ter que
falar aquilo que querem para não apanhar
nenhum choque disseram que se
ultrapassar o tempo paulinho chicão
espero ter aqui algum cuidado mexe e
importava falar que é é fusão entre o
homem ea máquina no presente já está a
acontecer todos nós temos qualquer
guerra no bolso
temos de apostar em hospitais nos
telemóveis estão ligados ao mundo as
redes
muitos dispositivos que significa que
quer queiramos quer não estamos a ter
uma fusão com as máquinas de forma é até
muito involuntária mas está a acontecer
até os nossos próprios comportamentos
é incrível ter a ideia de que em 2029 é
que existam um computador que tenha uma
capacidade cognitiva é suprir o a um
cérebro humano
o mais incrível é em 2045 pensarmos que
um computador tem é capacidade cognitiva
de o mundo o planeta todo todos os
servos do planeta tenha qualquer coisa
extraordinária há quem diga também há
quem defenda em 2045 será o marco
principal que atingiremos a
singularidade
tudo isto graças a toda é essa
o crescimento é exponencial que temos a
nível de tecnologia e claro que iremos
ter é o conceito do homem 2.0 e muita
gente defende que o homem é uma coisa é
a máquina é o outro eu penso que ele
enfrente o jogo que poderá haver sim a
união das duas coisas existir o homem e
máquina é em prol de um objetivo só em
comum tanto porém em para conseguirem
coexistir em simultâneo em sem andar
homem uma coisa máquina outra guerra
entre os dois movimentos e verá sempre a
tecnologia evolução traz sempre algum
mal mas neste caso aqui eu juro por
haver uma uma harmonia entre o homem ea
máquina e fazer um homem do estendido
digamos com informações mas é é falar em
acerto oficial que é tudo isto que nós é
é uma palavra muito já muito usada ela
está a ser usada cada vez mais nas
tecnologias que elevam depois a um
desenvolvimento mais fino há nenhuma
genoino fundo e são as máquinas que já
estão programadas para aprender por si
próprio e vencemos nós ensinar a elas
próprias aprendem e depois quem leva uma
outra camada mais evoluída do próprio da
própria inclusive sexual que o diploma
em que fazem um pensamento muito mais
alargado de muita informação para
executar uma outra opressões
claro que temos uma e tudo isto é é a
eterna natal reto que o fal q
infelizmente está a ser conhecida em
todo o mundo e esta renda e vai sair
esse precisamente nisso na inteligência
artificial e fazer é comunhão entre 1o o
ser humano e uma partida virtual e
consiga criar uma coisa que não é
é não pode ser vista a letra mas é
imortalizado digital ou seja é é a
personalidade de uma pessoa é gravado ao
por sadd enterrado e depois é guardada
no seu interior e e ser usava a
posteriori é é importante notar que no
futuro e podemos estar é interagir com
entidades já que não estamos a conhecer
no passado
ao contrário porque as memórias estão
guardadas mas não é um simples registro
de um arquivo é uma memória que interage
conosco mesmo depois de morrer nos lei
que têm estas foi uma volta do tema é um
estudo baseado em código como alguém já
dizia calma isto é código tanto é apenas
em transitar é essencial é trabalhar
neste neste sentido muito chama muito
bem louco é natural
muitos também diziam que este projecto
que era impossível já deixou já
ultrapassou a fase do impossível e já é
real
portanto eu gosto me dizer às pessoas
com tem um projeto um sonho é teres de
cabeça claro que habito isso também é
que ir mas essencialmente vantagem e é
por isso que o que eu gosto também
desafiar o impossível eu impossível pra
mim é o alimento que não faz tornar as
coisas possíveis
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]